[Music]
welcome back to JK news welcome back
we're gonna talk about the worker when
we talk about whatever the not I don't
think that's it
hey guys you're watching off and where
we talk about don't think that's it
alright so bad you know we could just
technically watch an off the record and
yeah you guys get the point
oh that's all record but sure dude okay
well yet so I guess we you can't replace
her it's just everything is ruined now
that's so true case is cuter though
Casey is a cuter computer face to look
at no hey thank you for the coffee by
the way this has been a good fun little
marathon that we've been doing this is
day two yeah I think it's pretty fun
doing this man I I kind of want to do
this schedule if it's post quarantine
two longer breaks and back-to-back days
yeah cuz I don't know that maybe if it's
my personality to do things like binge
and immerse stuff and then I think the
more date that I do it the better I'm
getting at it and I hosted all day
yesterday that's true so you don't
forget what happened like last week how
do i how do I work this Google sheet no
it's more like just being better at
speaking and doing this particular skill
and then you take a little break from it
and you've come back holder to the break
like a month no that's too long I'll go
crazy maybe two weeks two or three weeks
yeah yeah I definitely feel like
yesterday I was much more vocal to the
point where I got home and I was like
this better not be the Rona's
I love in my throat you always think
about it now because like everyone's
like so scared like even if you like
have a tick what you're like oh yeah
don't even Dory's I had a point
yesterday where I was like I want to
clear my throat I don't want to seem
suspicious the bathroom and then clear
my throat I mean if I'm like that to the
point where like my neighbors are just
walking their dogs and I think says it's
so sensitive right now I had a neighbor
who's walking his dog and he's my I'm
wait
that's true go back to China white guy
[Laughter]
my sneeze and cough meters like [ __ ]
going off the charts dude especially
like in a plane or something mm-hmm dude
I was hypersensitive
coming back from Europe as soon as I
heard a sneeze or a cough and they might
be like in first class or something you
know I'm just like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude when you go grocery shopping do you
feel like you're instantly sick like
while you're there for some reason sorry
what happen right like you can't get
sicker fast but while I'm there I'm just
like oh man am I am i coming down
because all these people am I getting a
coffee right now because you're next to
me are you walking to the freezer
section cuz it is cold there yeah it
main lungs tighten around the freezer
section everyone has a mask and then the
I firstly told you only wear one when
you have symptoms yeah I see let's pray
don't wear one if you don't so when you
go there in everyone's way when you're
like when when people made that
announcement because people who are
paranoid just word anyways yeah yeah my
friend just announced that she has it
what yeah someone you know personally
has two people now one of my friends
just posted yesterday that two of her
friends just passed away I'm like oh
[ __ ]
this is that they had and they passed
away I never yeah they're 30 so yeah are
these like real friends because you know
some people don't you know my home but
just win it to jail man it's so [ __ ]
sad and it's like a neighbor's questions
yeah you're like what the second grade
with them they're real people
my friend and then we were just talking
about something else and Hopper was one
of the parties she does and then she was
like by the way I got her owners know
she was just like I felt like sick last
night I fainted and everything I was
like so for me all you fainted I never
heard anyone that sounds like a booty
call edition want you to come over you
wanted you to catch her like this you're
not getting enough uh yeah my pussy's
wet for some reason come over and help
me I wish can you leave like can you eat
me back to life these like I already
jacked off I'm sorry
I feel like goes like that in a sense I
feel like that's like the opposite of
one where I'm trying to go over it she's
like yeah I'm sick you know yeah so then
she like I was texting and she wasn't
texting for a few days I say what the
house aw I just thought like yeah but
then uh then she announced that she was
like she had this and that she was going
to like all like the symptoms and
everything and she was like it like
which ones like diarrhea coughing like
the coughing breathing even in the video
she's like I don't about the diarrhea as
much as they're coughing oh I got these
symptoms not a don't worry I don't have
the diarrhea even though they actually
might have it I was like damn because
it's who's telling like the last time I
spoke to her she was like yeah failing
last night I'm feeling a little under
the weather but I didn't know people
could faint from it's always your slave
there's people that go into comas from
it yeah doesn't a big thing that
happened either so crazy their lung
capacity they can't even though they're
breathing the even if they breathe
normally it can't take in the same
amount of oxygen like their oxygen
levels will go down to 90 to 80 percent
like that choking and yeah they'll like
end up taking longer naps and then
eventually they might like pass out so
just if you pass out be aware some chips
earlier and in the store said no mask no
service yeah well that's it the rule
that I the mayor said but I feel like
nobody's obeying it so there's obviously
more people now but when I go to the
store now I still see people without it
I mean they're fining people thousand
dollars it really I know in Texas at
least but I think California there was
mentions of it but I don't know if it's
like official official I know my friends
in Hawaii they were like my friends or
my neighbors a party in a mascot
yeah you have to go in the water
like my neighbor was throwing a party
and I wanted to go over and tell them
something I don't want to call the cops
because if you call the cops it's $5,000
for them but then I don't know how
they're gonna because also sometimes
call lines and you'll escape so choose
she was like I don't want to know the
same thing yeah have you guys been to a
store where you're the only one not
wearing a mask
yeah I've been smart you been smart yeah
I got been smart as in avoiding stores
or you've been going with masses no with
my ass like I don't know some stores as
often but like when I do I would wear a
mask cuz I got those reusable ones that
you wash and so sad he's always wearing
a mask man yeah I'm such a troll we're
like I want to buy that mask where it is
your face put it on it people get mad at
me first and that can come about closer
all right oh oh but then we break the
six-feet thing on I hope by 6 feet they
could see that it's big oh we gotta go
like this you made me take it off I had
it on are you guys like afraid that all
Ardmore is just like the paranoia that's
getting to you
well it's getting closer and closer
because both cases were just talking
about how like we don't have anyone in
like two or three degrees of separation
yeah although we know that it's real and
it's a crazy thing it doesn't feel like
it's at your doorstep yeah but now it's
like these two exchanges I'm like like I
want to go home the good thing is like
all the people that I know that have
guarded or like the people that I've
seen online it always come now like I
was an idiot I still went to like see
some these people I stopped now I still
not passing but in like I've never seen
someone that was like yeah staying at
home while all they wanted to go see
like a league in a safe way seeing like
friends are so close ones on the Veeder
like shouldn't have suck all that dick
oh yeah that was quarantine and chilling
damn man the first week everyone was
like all like this is gonna suck I'm not
gonna be able to see like my boyfriend
or like a hookup whatever and then you
could tell it after the first week
everyone's like [ __ ] it one person or
two people it's fine and then they start
going out I started doing that and then
it's nice building back up yeah and one
person to like especially the young
people I've seen online I think they're
the ones that are like oh sure now it's
gonna be May 15th it's gonna be June oh
I gotta get some [ __ ] yeah they're like
I'm gonna go out I'm gonna do this I
[ __ ] out you know like those spring
breakers the ones that don't care though
they were just dumped from the beginning
yeah well I mean anyone that does that I
feel like is I mean I was done from the
beginning I don't think I was taking it
into consideration as much as I am now
like as I learned more than more I'm
like oh [ __ ] like like I was on a path
of not really caring as much you know
I'm late it's not affecting me directly
in like you know and especially during
the times when like I think people are
already kind of scared cuz like China
and like all the other countries that
were affected and like us it didn't have
a lockdown yet but people were choosing
to self quarantine already during that
time I was like this is stupid
come on guys they may live your life
don't be so like scared or whatever but
now I'm like [ __ ] I'm kind of like
eating my own words cuz I'm can you
scared I'm murdering that time is so
hard for people to block the line
between like trying to alert people but
not be an alarmist so every like every
news person was like okay we have an
expert on valois and not to be an
alarmist but everything is terrible and
there's like trying to like not scare
people but scam people just enough it
but it never really works cuz it's like
it's either you're scared and you're
gonna talk to all precautions you can or
just not yeah cuz if you if you just
scare people here people go crazy yeah I
think I'm more scared of that I'm scared
of Americans panicking and being afraid
it's not looting of breaking grocery
stores they're American panic the toilet
paper though I know my even more
physical violence
they're gonna shoot for toilet paper
next you know dumb they should have
panic bidet like me I felt so bad I went
to the grocery store like maybe a week
after and then obviously they're still
not toilet paper so no toilet paper now
yeah but those old man asking when the
ladies and I he's very old and you tone
his voice he's like I need toilet paper
right I don't have it at home he doesn't
have any
and then the lazy it's also doubted he's
like what do you mean like I need and
like you could tell like he was like
almost like bring it out he's like I
need toilet paper I was like dad like
these are people that are getting
affected cuz they
rush to the store they can't care did
you offer on one role I didn't have any
you don't have any either
I had some of the house he just sorry
old man I think I just want a new job
you're all use the handkerchief miss
Lee's not that bad if you don't have
toilet paper we're all at home take a
shower take a [ __ ] and just jump in the
shower and wipe your butt use the hose
like I think don't think like that Bo I
suppose the older people that are just
so used to doing in a certain way where
we could be resourceful but they're just
like I just wide that said they've ran
out of TV than toilet paper I thought I
was at a store right and I don't have
bought that home yeah you've got a
finger toilet paper or a TV I'm like
I'll wash my ass in the bathroom I think
some people probably never watched ass
before
that's true what a paper dependent
people have not done it well like our
ancestors all wash their asses with a
cup yeah yeah well relief yeah yeah go
out to the lawn and just like wipe your
butt on the line I started doing that
when I was like 13 when I first went to
Southeast Asia that's when I learned
like they litter the way that they take
showers and [ __ ] is they fill up a like
a trash bin size bucket thing with water
and it's just or rain collected water or
well water this warm water or you know
heated water room temperature okay but
it's hot outside though so it feels good
it's literally like you see an outhouse
right so they got the they have the
[ __ ] like toilet that's on the floor
and then next to it it's a drain and if
they have that bucket thing and you just
use that and then use that same little
pot bucket thing to [ __ ] wipe your
ass with first and I was it was it was
like mind blowing because it was the
first time squatting it was the first
time wiping my ass with just water and
then feeling like weird afterwards you
got a few user in hand still or just the
waters enough no you have to use your
hands in between it but it's like taking
a shower oh yeah but then yeah
afterwards like they say like you should
bring a little towel in there so you
could wipe well but it's just it's just
like rinsing off in the shower and
wiping your butt and then you just leave
yeah my first time I went to Vietnam as
a little kid all such a like
American like Priss right I was like cuz
first time with the Vietnam the
technology what isn't where it is today
right today everything is all modern
right they even have hot water then so I
had my real yeah I had my family boil up
hot pot of water I can shower with the
combination of some cold water and some
hot I was just looking at you like he's
[ __ ] little [ __ ] yeah no one boils
water my water heater went out last week
didn't wash so like I had to learn how
to fix it before that I was just like
cold water and ice were tea it was like
I couldn't do it yeah you can do it was
freezing in the middle of winter right
now right yeah so the outsider just was
caught like literally wouldn't go from
freezing imagine you got like just the
quarter setting on any ice cubes coming
it was like saying that I was lure just
grabbing water letting get warm in my
head got a train for you okay you just
jump in because I heard it's good for
you : it is but then the you know what
the truth is so like winter here is
nothing compared to winter in your eyes
yeah I'll do it at the coldest setting
here and I'm I could do it now and then
we we would go to the [ __ ] waterfall
right here by the hike and you know how
it's like melted ice I could do it right
I try to take a cold shower in Europe
yeah it's another level of cold man the
tap it comes out like ice cold I try to
drink the water burn my [ __ ] teeth
and [ __ ] yeah I can't do cold showers
like there because it's just too cold
yeah I'm like how do you how do you get
water so cold it's like burning the way
I do it here I have to do it like I'm
getting in a pool I like the shower
running I just got a job it's cool the
best place to just jump in and I have to
do this what do [ __ ] I gotta go ahead I
can't go a leg first and then check oh
yeah it that [ __ ] me up dude I gotta go
head first just let it go to my back and
I'm just and yeah yeah
ooh a about Europe we passed the the
deaths in America from Italy yeah we
have the most in the world right now
yeah but we also have a bigger
population and it makes sense yeah we
have the bigger population of idiots
that's that's true but we also have what
three hundred million people compared to
I don't know what they have I don't know
what terms that infected no no humans
just like population so like it's almost
like comparing the whole of Europe
continent that's how we should look at
the numbers yeah the whole of your
Europe continent and then the US because
Italy is is just like Wisconsin or
something probably
well yeah like maybe like Florida or
like whatever their population it's
probably similar to that so I'm also
looking at density and population
Italy's pretty bad for that size because
of density and how many old people would
stand and all that cuz I was looking at
numbers in Taiwan how many people are in
California like 40 million Taiwan is
doing still well right yeah so like
Taiwan they have the whole country which
is like smaller than from LA to San
Francisco yeah there's 38 million so
there's less than California um I think
yeah they're doing really well cuz I
think what happened was like the who
pretty much didn't really consider them
a nation so they just abandoned them
so Taiwan's I will tell [ __ ] Taiwan owes
that well we just have to take things
into our own hands they did a really
good job another how social distancing
right now they people people practice it
but it's not there's not that's not a
law fees cover he's not a law people
just moving around going about but if
they already find the curve long time
ago that's true because our buddy went
back to Taiwan um right before
everything happened so so it was closer
to China when the whole outbreak was
there and America was still partying and
relaxing right I think we even sent
masks during that time to China and my
friend was like oh man it sucks here
everything no one's out so they faced
what we did months ago yeah yeah well we
was here December it was until what did
I hear no no our buddy was here like
January was his early January January
yeah so by the time he went back to
Taiwan
dirty what were face
right now in April they did in January
and that's when Korea and all them were
like really tighten up their [ __ ] you
know took about four months for them to
recover them basically and they were in
April and they're now yeah but that very
little deaths I think they did a really
good job immediately assembling yes I've
in Korea they had like little self
quarantines and cars and then that's how
like they were able to check everybody
in these cars like efficiently and
quickly to see if anyone tested positive
they tested a lot they were known for
doing really well dude yeah this whole
thing was that they tested everybody not
just if you had symptoms yeah and they
just had more tests available like they
didn't have a situation with everything
all we don't have enough we can't test
you today why is it that US has none we
don't have enough tests for we didn't
want to take what the what they made
globally so they made test kits early in
like Europe and stuff and then the u.s.
was like oh we'll make our own so we're
not gonna use the global it's not
American test but although I think
there's politics involved because I
think they were trying to hold off for
as long as possible and they're even now
at the hospitals are just testing in
general it's not happening like Korea's
testing everyone even if they're not
sick or whatever out here they're
finding reasons why they shouldn't test
you hmm
same with Europe like the way that they
were doing it was like all unless you
have a fever we're not gonna test you
cuz my friend was trying to get tested
cuz everyone was like oh I wanted to be
sure I want to get tested they're like
oh well you know you have a sore throat
or you just that's it okay well just
stay home how do you celebs get tested
money do you feel like this is gonna
change how the world is after this hell
yeah dude I think I think one of the
main reasons why Asia was a little bit
more prepared was because they had SARS
and so like they kind of knew how to
handle something very similar they have
a pandemic like every few years dude do
you lie it's gonna be different for
American because like now we know how
bad our health care system is 43 we're
just gonna forget after a year they're
gonna like have some other like scandal
or something that we're just gonna take
our mind off because we did experience
the Spanish flu here in the states but
it's it's weird because like Japan
continued the the habits after spam
fool I call this like this came from
Spanish Flu would you work out when you
go back to the gym with a mask well you
know me weird I think I'm more of like a
social acceptance person everyone's
doing it I'll do it but then yeah it
feels weird okay I guess you know we're
gonna still see people out wearing masks
like months after this yeah wasn't just
the Chinese people so I have a vision I
have a friend that uh keys I can he
works a lot of big brands and stuff and
he said one of the masks companies that
he works with
they just greenlit like a NBA license so
that's how big it's supposed to be it
supposed to be like face mask with MBA
yeah like there's gonna be Lakers
Chicago ball thanks Matt so like it's
the pattern or the playing it they're
wearing during the game I don't know
they're the pattern like to be able to
use a logo the point is like it's it's
gonna be as commonplace or they think
it's gonna be as commonplace as like New
Era hats it's like yeah yeah or like
jerseys like it's gonna be like that so
that's how big they think it's going to
be like it's gonna be the norm Japan has
a Pokemon mask yeah no like there's a
lot of Americans I'm gonna go to Japan
and Tokyo like they'll wear the mask
they think it's cool they think it's
like alright looks like a ninja whatever
yeah like social media is weird too
they're like that's cultural
appropriation you're not supposed to
wear a mask or whatever they got cool
ass patterns this is
this is Western yeah I know came to
Japan and during the Spanish flu era in
our era in our generation anyone
actually associates that with the
Western culture they associate that with
an Asian thing that's true yeah but now
yeah it's coming back that's true
because a lot of dude I even had a white
family at the airport in Tokyo they were
asking me there like excuse me he's like
why are people wearing surgical masks
cuz they're all surgeons right I didn't
know and I was like oh it's cuz if
they're sick or whatever but yeah a lot
of people just wish I think that was a
big culture shock for a lot of people
back then when they would see if you go
to Japan like you know you see in
postcards and you see in TV you'll see
people wearing the masks until you're
there and you're like damn why the [ __ ]
are they where are they about to do
operations and [ __ ] no cuz they're being
a decent human being and not
affect other people no they're like wow
that stereotype is true
all of them are dog
[Music]